one of my favorite parts of this movie
is how many characters process things
that are happening via movies TV shows
and books so for you too as in real you
what movie show or book weighs on your
mind most during the day where you
process real world things through that
story
real world
shows
I don't know
I would say anytime I'm in downtown L.A
The Last of Us comes to mind good choice
you know you know how it embeds into it
you know I'm just thinking oh they could
pop out any minute I almost kind of put
myself in that scenario you know I'm
glad you want genre because mine is
Final Destination oh look around and I'm
like something's gonna fall out oh that
yeah on set that's you know because a
lot of things that happened on set the
construction the scaffolding yeah that
gets me on set that's a girl that's a
good one that's a good one I could live
with I could yeah I could go in that way
anytime you see tree logs on the back of
a truck it's like move me you move get
from the behind this yeah no Tree Lodge
on trucks no tanning beds I can go on
and on yeah so for you two and also
Jamie I love talking about the value of
a good scene partner and the three of
you have exceptional chemistry with one
another can you each tell me something
about the other two that you really
appreciated as a scene partner and you
think brought something out of your own
character that you wouldn't have been
able to reach without them for sure I'll
start
um with Jamie just he was was so
generous with like jokes it was times
where I'm like my character yo-yo would
definitely be able to come back at you
harder than Tiana can process to come
back at you so he would offer me jokes
and I just think that's so dope like
he's like here's a joke that will cut me
down that make me look crazy him
um and so that was dope and then with
John John really was a metronome for us
like uh you have yo-yo and Slick who are
so high energy and just or yo-yo's very
high energy slick is what he is but
John's character Fontaine acted as a
metronome and so inevitably I think I
don't know I can't speak for him but
John also bought like a very calm smooth
just chill energy to the trio that
um helped to balance you know I don't
say that the extroverted high energy
from from yo-yo kind of teaches you your
place in a sense and then but yet still
gives the gang that some some form of
energy that keeps you you know motivated
as you go for a scene and with Jamie is
just the ability to improv and just to
get a scene on paper about to be able to
kind of like shake it up a little bit
you know give us new ideas and just kind
of give you the freedom to be able to
imagine a little bit more you know
that's that's real cool between that
Vibe and also there's so many lines the
three of you deliver that like I
couldn't hear delivered any other way
there's like a very specific like pitch
and tone to it that feels so specific to
the three of you and I love it yeah
thank you so how about Joelle now
because I just have a very good feeling
that there will be many many more films
for him on the horizon so what's
something you appreciated about him as
an actor's director that you are very
excited for more actors to get to
experience in the future with them for
me what I think Jewel does very well is
the overall vision and giving me
references if I had any questions or
being able to say oh maybe not that
let's you know kind of bring it back a
little bit but really he just let us
really go for it because we're genre
Less in the fact that we have all the
genres and we're era Less in the fact
that it's any era um we really got to
play around and so
um he just started with a very strong
point of view and a very strong vision
and allowed me to play Within that left
me alone unless I I just have that
respectful honesty industry thing you
know I mean when director doesn't want
to say he doesn't have that he's just
straight up just kind of like
yeah man this high for the turn should
be or this is how you know we should
hold it back at this moment or we should
do more I just like the freedom and the
honesty you know it's just uh gives a
fresh perspective to the experience does
he have a monitor dance like when you
crush a take does he do anything
specific that signals to you that he
likes it behind the monitor oh crispy
okay
I like that I could picture it I can
picture it so you brought up you know
the the many genres not knowing
specifically what time this movie takes
place and there's so many little details
here so when you first sign on what is
like your biggest burning question about
your character or the scenario overall
that you absolutely needed him to answer
to be able to fully wrap your head
around this whole thing uh for me I
think it was the ending I don't know how
much we can talk about but if you want
we can say this is when the spoiler
warning calls up and then people will
have something to enjoy after they watch
this spoiler alert for me the thing I
needed the most help with was
um
when so yeah I don't know I don't know
how to talk about it but uh I don't
because I'm trying not to do a spoiler
tone as well you were talking about that
with you the time yeah okay let's talk
about that then uh I think I really
needed a little yeah
um one of the things I really wanted
Joel to help me with was tone in the
sense of yo yo can be very excitable and
very high energy and I loved that about
her
and I wanted to I I saw that for her and
I wanted to make sure that in creating
this woman that it didn't tip the scales
too far over but I think that's what was
awesome was that John's character
Fontaine is such a a metronome and a
calming force with it calming Force
but you know a a different energy that
is very much needed um but that's what I
really needed Jewel to help me with was
tone like is it too much do I can I go
further that sort of thing some
characterization stuff you know helped
me out of accent
um and just you know body language how
to differentiate the different clones
um and just the little stuff like that
but Joelle is so particular that he's
the right type of director for this type
of job can you give me an example of
something he was really particular about
that someone might someone might say
like that is not an important detail but
it wound up being key to Bringing
everything together and you appreciate
that it was actually fontaine's look
like we I even I hadn't found the
character until we found the look it was
that you know you come downstairs and
Joel just be like this you can check out
the beard first check out the grills
check out the hair and it was so
particular about this look what
silhouette was Fontaine gonna make how
I'd move within the silhouette also so
the look was very he was very particular
on now I can see that all right as I
have to wind down the inevitable
Marvel's question but in in particular I
want to ask about working with Nia again
which I think could be a safe way to get
at it having worked together on Candyman
what is something she did on the marbles
that makes you say like I knew you could
do that I knew you would crush it but
then on the other hand like a layer of
her ability as a director that was
illuminated on that project she was
going to be in the Kang Dynasty being
nice what is this
about plot specifically I mean Mia's
growth is a direct Mia is
um Nia is so dope and the fact that you
know Candyman was I mean let's just be
clear the marbles is a lot bigger budget
to work with in a bigger uh Universe I
mean that is not a spoiler alert so to
watch her be able to in in this sci-fi
world you know like we were doing horror
before it's just to get to see it felt
like a more freedom and I can't speak
for her but this is what it felt like
for me just to
um in the world she got to create and
the things she got to bring to life from
her her mind uh with us uh I feel as if
I got to see her do even more of that in
this world I like that so you are an
Avenger then
all the resources all the creative
control in her hands please
congratulations on this it is something
else